- Hi, everyone, a very good
afternoon to all of you.
Hope you all have been
having a good day today,
lot of sessions.
And today, we are here to discuss
about how at CCC Intelligent Solutions,
we were able to achieve and improve
our operational efficiency
with database modernization
from Oracle to AWS Aurora Postgres.
We have a very nice agenda
over here for today.
The first one, I will try to explain
why data is critical for CCC.
I'll give you brief
background on what is CCC,
and then I will explain or take you all
through our cloud journey.
But to understand all of these,
we need to understand why we did it,
how we did it, and what did we get
after achieving or
completing this journey?
So to start with, CCC is a
leader as a SaaS provider
to provide solutions for auto claims
and collision repair industry.
We help all the auto insurers,
we help repair shops,
automakers, parts suppliers,
and other vendors
to automate and streamline
their claim processing workflow.
We build solutions for the repair shops
to streamline their repair process,
and we provide, as part
of our SaaS platform,
AI-enabled advanced solutions
so that they can maintain
and manage their claim
cycle for their customers.
Now, when we talk about our customers,
maybe the customers are auto
insurers or repair shops,
but at the end of the day,
their customers are our customers.
So what we try to do or
how we help our customers
is to turn all these
data points into actions,
and all their key moments
into intelligent experiences.
It's never a great experience
to be in an auto accident
and go through that journey,
so we try our best to
provide simplified solutions
to make their journey
through that claim cycle
better and smoother.
Kind of what sets CCC apart
is we are industry leader
in collision estimating
solution provider,
and also, what we do is as part
of helping our customer's customer,
we also help our customers
to fuel their growth.
Now, if I talk about data, what we do
or what we process in
through our SaaS platform
is we process around 18
million claims over a year,
which is close to 50,000
to 55,000 per day.
I may be talking about claims,
but think about these from
a human point of view,
like 50,000 accidents or
50,000 claims every day,
that means we are touching
at least 50,000 human lives
at any point of time in a particular day.
So who do we work with?
We have top 300 auto insurers.
Our solutions are implemented
by 35,000 repair shops
across United States.
We have our integration
with 5,000 suppliers
through which we do parts procurement,
and then we integrate with
top 12 of top 15 automakers
to do our integration with OEM providers.
Now, all through this, CCC's primary focus
is when an auto collision
estimating processing,
the claim is going
through all its process,
it generates a huge amount of data.
Now, how we differentiate from others
are we take these data points,
we create intelligent reasons out of it,
we create prediction out of it,
and then all these data turns
into a predictive solution,
and we have AI-enabled
analytics on top of it
to help our customers.
As I mentioned, we have
around 5,000 parts suppliers
who do we direct integration with them.
We have 12 OEM providers
who we are directly
integrated with.
Now, this is all I said about what
was CCC Intelligent Solution
and its SaaS platform,
but we started this journey back in 2022
to support our growth, to scale ourselves,
to provide our customers the platform
for their growth, also.
Now, what we did, how did we achieve
our cloud modernization journey?
Initially, what we did
is we broke that apart
into three cycles.
The first cycle we did was we
focused on the infrastructure.
The second, we looked
into the application tier,
and then the third and the
last one was the database.
You can ask why database was the last one,
because our core business
sits inside that data.
As I mentioned, we rely
on data very heavily,
so we kept that towards the end.
First, we looked into the infrastructure,
we modernized the infrastructure layer
from migrating all our workload
from on-prem to AWS Cloud
so that we can have more freedom,
and we can have a better
and faster scalable options.
Then what we did is we
went through a complete
application modernization.
Earlier, we were pretty kind of tied up
with vendor solutions,
so what we did is we went for
a more open-source approach
where we migrated our
Oracle WebLogic workloads
into microservices and JBUS,
then we migrated our service
with components from Oracle
to MuleSoft,
and then we leveraged
more of Kafka architecture
to get into even giving
architecture design.
Then came last as the database part,
which was the heavy lift for us.
As I already mentioned, that we process
close to 50,000 claims per day,
which turns into around 18 million,
and then on top of that, if
you look at every transaction
or every action which happens
on a particular claim,
it turns out that our databases process
almost 50,000 transactions per second,
so you can imagine how
busy that database is.
There are tons of applications,
small applications,
talking to each other, tightly integrated
so that it can manage each
touching point smoothly
without any failure,
so there are, like,
hundreds of applications.
We need to think that how
we will simplify them.
So we took this approach,
infrastructure was done,
then as a second step,
we finished the application modernization,
and then we started the journey
of database modernization.
Earlier, like when we were on on-prem,
and even after we moved
to AWS Cloud initially
with our infrastructure,
our applications were
running on Oracle Database.
So what we said is that we looked
into our database modernation as a project
or as a full challenge,
and then we said that,
"Let's go through what
are the challenges we have
to accomplish this journey?"
So the first one was that we had to look
into all our databases,
and I think it'll be
applicable for all of you
if you're going through that journey.
You need to identify all
the integration points
into that database.
You need to identify all the sources
which are going to put data into it.
You need to identify all
the downstream applications
which are going to
either read or come back
and update those data points.
We went through that analysis,
and we identified that
what are all the dependency
between each of them,
so that one, I can do a
divide and rule approach.
I say that all the components
or applications which are independent,
I will first put them into
a phase one deliverable,
and then I will look into
all the dependency-heavy
applications and see
how I can them further.
When I'm talking about
hundreds of applications,
I'm talking about close to,
like, more than 50,000 SQLs,
which were kind of implemented
through those applications
which were running when
all these applications
generate workload into the databases.
So what we did is we
went through analyzing
all those Oracle-native SQLs,
and we tried to analyze them,
how many of them are easily transportable
or can be migrated into
a PostgreSQL structure?
And then also we looked into a lot of SQLs
which we could kind of tune or modify
so that it can fit easily into
the Postgres architecture.
The next challenge was the data migration,
where you can work
through your application,
you can work through your SQLs,
but our data migration was the next step,
and on an average, the
amount of data we have
in all our databases was
more than 150 terabytes,
and one of them was even
close to 100 terabytes.
So what we had to do is we
needed to find a solution
where I can take in all
these hundred terabytes
and fit it into a Oracle
Postgres engine architecture,
which was a tough challenge for all of us,
but while we were going through
all these modernization,
we are trying to find solution
for all these challenges,
there was one constant
factor in all of those.
There was no compromise
on our SLOs or SLAs,
because business has to run as is.
So that was our primary goal number one,
that any simplification,
any modernization,
any improvement, any tuning
we are trying to come up with
has to meet those SLAs or even better.
So what we did?
Now, with all this journey,
there always has to be a risk, correct?
As I mentioned, there are tons of data,
there are tons of different data types,
there are different applications
accessing those data
more or less at the same
point in time concurrently.
So what we had to do?
Now, I cannot come and
go to business, say that,
"Okay, all these products applications
will not be available for six months,
because we are going
through this journey,"
so how I can mitigate that risk?
So what we did is we created a isolated,
separated test environment
where we were able
to take the production, like data,
we are able to generate
production, like a load volume,
so that I can not only
test my compatibility
of my applications into
the Postgres architecture,
but also ensure that the
performance efficiency
hasn't been compromised.
So what we did is we built
a separate test environment
for all of us to try out
all these code changes,
all these SQL changes,
test our compatibility,
test our performance,
and then the next challenge,
as I mentioned earlier,
was how to fit into 100 terabytes
or more than 100 terabytes of data worth
into Aurora Postgres.
As we all know, Aurora
Postgres has a limitation
of maximum amount of storage it can hold.
So what we did was we went
back to our Oracle Database,
and we started to analyze
different types of data
which we were storing in that database,
which I think is always
going to be critical part
if you're going through that
database modernization journey.
We went through, we first identified
that if there are any binary data,
which were stored on the Oracle Database,
if those can be migrated
out of a database.
Again, these databases were used by a lot
of legacy applications,
so we identified there's a lot of storage
is used by this binary
data, such as BLOB and CLOB,
where we used to store our documents,
images related to,
associated to those claims.
So we came up with our approach.
We built automation to migrate
close to 30 to 40 terabytes of data,
all this binary data out
of these Oracle Database
and migrate it over to S3 first
before even we migrate rest
of the data into Postgres.
So if you try to understand the breakdown
of these database migration journey,
first we analyze the database types,
like all the data types,
we analyze the data,
we analyze what is binary
and what is non-binary,
we identified and marked down,
and came up with an approach to migrate
all those binary data from
our Oracle Database to S3.
Now, what I have been left
with is all the non-binary data
which are sitting on the Oracle.
There comes how I will transfer
all those non-binary data
from Oracle to Postgres,
so challenge is Postgres doesn't
support all the data types
in comparison to Oracle.
Thus, the team came up with an approach.
There were different tools available to us
to run some analysis
and generate a report,
and we did a comparison
between a data type,
let's say, a number data
type in Oracle Database
to a numeric data type in Postgres,
how that conversion can happen.
You will always end up with challenges
when there are precisions
kind of included in your data.
If you have decimal values,
if you have, like,
non-full numeric values,
that is always a risk
when you migrate it over
to your Postgres engine.
So with all these challenges,
once we were done with all
this risk mitigation approach,
we went to our solution details.
So all those database workloads
which were independent of each other,
what we did is we simplified
them out of these databases
from the central core
database, Oracle Database,
and we created individual
dedicated Postgres databases
for those application workload.
That help us to trim the fat out of it.
Now, comes to the core meat, correct?
That still has close to 60
terabytes of data for me
with all the complex data type columns.
Not to worry.
The next set of challenge was
there were a lot of tables
which were used by ETLs,
staging tables, no primary key.
So good luck with your data transfer
when any tool doesn't understand
what is the reliability
of the transfer of these datasets
which do not have any primary key,
whether it has been successfully migrated
to the destination or not.
So to achieve this data transfer
from Oracle to Postgres,
we leveraged AWS's data DMS solution.
The tool comes in kind of a lot
of out-of-the-box configuration,
but for us, we had to do
a lot of customization,
particularly on busy
transactional databases
such as which was supporting
50,000 transactions per second.
It was always a battle with
how to configure the DMS
up to a kinda maximum and correct point
so that it supports that transaction rate,
because, one, I cannot put a
load on my source database,
because I cannot impact my business.
It has to run as usual,
but at the same time, I need to maintain
my DMS transfer rate so that
I'm not lagging behind a lot
to try move that data into the Postgres,
because if your lag is too much,
then we all all know
that the DMS will break,
because it will find it
difficult to keep track
of those thinking points,
and at one point of time,
it will just just break up,
and it will say, "I am way behind in this,
so please come back and start me again."
So there were certain challenges
on that data transfer exercise.
And I already mentioned there
were not a one-to-one mapping
when we were talking about converting
a table data type column
from Oracle to Postgres.
There were certain data types
which were not supported on Postgres,
there were certain data
types which were created
or designed in a little bit
different way in Postgres
compared to Oracle.
So how can I know when I
have close to 50 schemas
across 15 databases,
and if I take all my lifecycle
of that particular environment,
if I duplicate it across
five different environments,
I'm talking about close
to 100 database instances
with 200 to 300 schemas.
So what we did is we,
again, went back to AWS,
we used their SCT tool
to do initial schema conversion.
Now, what this tool will do,
it will look into your source schemas,
it will go through and
analyze and translate
all the individual database objects
which are on Oracle side.
You can take tables, be
it views, your procedures,
your Oracle functions,
and then what it will do
is it'll run an assessment,
and it will generate a report
at the end of the execution.
And what it will do is it
will basically provide you
three information.
One, how much out-of-the-box
conversion can be done.
For example, it can
generate a script for you,
and it will tell that out of
these 100 database objects,
"70 of them are straightaway
one-to-one conversion,
I will generate a script for you."
And then for stored procedures,
or for some other complex data types,
it will give you an option,
but you have to manually create a script
or customize your configuration
to support that transformation.
And then for the rest third,
which is the most challenging group,
is it will say that it cannot
be converted by this SCT tool.
So what you have to do, you have to go,
you have to review them manually,
and then rewrote all
those database objects,
procedures as function,
or all those logic in a
Postgres-compatible SQL.
So again, what we did is we
did not do everything at once.
We did all these in an iterative manner,
and then we did all this,
we did this in phases,
and then slowly moved one pace at a time,
which is very critical if
your database is complex,
if your database size is larger.
Now, this journey took
us close to three years,
and I'm sure everyone
would be interested to know
that three years of investment
of working through this modernization,
working through this cloud transformation,
at the end of the day, what
it gives back to us, correct?
That's where the buck
stops, is the dollar value,
but sometimes the dollar
value is not direct, correct?
It can be direct, it can be indirect,
particularly in the operation world.
Most of the time, it is indirect.
So how we can justify that
return value out of this journey?
So what are all the benefits we received
as part of this journey?
What we have observed so far,
after working through this modernization
and completing this journey,
that we have achieved and
improved operational efficiency.
It helped us to sustain the
same performance throughput,
in some cases, even better.
It helped us to have a
optimized cost strategy.
As we started using a lot of
managed database solutions
provided by AWS,
it was easy for our FinOps team to come up
with a better prediction and forecast
so that we can manage
our cost in a better way.
We were able to engage
our site reliability team
and DevOps team to focus
on more automation,
more scripting, so that
we can leverage those
and optimize our cloud management.
Those procedures were
pretty proven procedures.
Some we were able to
leverage provided by AWS,
some were built and
developed by our own teams,
and that help us to enforce and expedite
our automation track.
The next one, what I'm
going to highlight over here
is with all this,
we were not only able to achieve
an improved RTO and RPO capabilities,
but we were also able to have
a better sustainable strategy.
How we were able to achieve it?
We were able to create
a plan in some cases
where we can use multi-ASE
across the same region.
And then we created a kind
of East-West region strategy
where we can use West as our
disaster recovery solution
or sustainable recovery solution,
and then use East region
as our primary production.
And then by leveraging
AWS-managed solution,
what we were able to
achieve is an improved
security footprint.
We did not have to worry a lot
the way we used to think
about our security compliance
when we were running
an on-prem with Oracle.
Scaling opportunity, again,
it enabled us to grow faster
if there were any faster
go-to-market requirements,
so that we are able to scale faster there,
and then we were able to
support our business growth.
There was no pushback from
technology to business,
saying that if there is a new
requirement or new workload,
or it is going to take us months.
No, it's days.
You give us the requirement,
we run through the new workload pattern
in our performance test environment.
Once it gets certified,
you are ready to go
to move it to production
as long as you are hitting
all the checklist and check marks
for your production readiness.
And then the next best thing
which happened, as I mentioned,
that every time it is
not direct dollar impact,
with operation is a better and
proactive incident management
with a lot of automation
and auto-remediation.
So when everything was
running on managed solutions,
we were able to focus on
our incident management,
on our runbook,
we were able to automate our SOPs.
In a lot of cases, we are
able to eliminate those SOPs
with a better modernization
on the application
and database layer.
Now, I would like to highlight
what kind of infrastructure
we were running before we were
running on Aurora Postgres,
and I am trying to say
that it is cost effective,
it is operational efficiency effective,
why it gives us a better sleep at night
than those sleepless days in on-prem.
So before Aurora Postgres,
we were running our database workload
on a Oracle RAC cluster.
Earlier, we were running
on the extra data.
Now, after we moved to AWS,
we are running on the
custom Oracle RAC on AWS.
We were running on a RAC
cluster with nine nodes,
and all those nodes at that point of time,
were running on the largest instance type,
whatever AWS was providing at that time.
All of them were 32xlarge.
This is just to manage
the workload distribution
so that, one, I'm not creating
a single point of failure,
and second, is the load
is well-distributed.
We all know, with Oracle,
you can create services,
distribute your application workload,
but this is a huge server.
Not only your monthly billing
meter goes high with this,
but also, it's a operational headache.
You think about patching,
you think about managing all
these nine-node RAC cluster
day in, day out,
it's a nightmare for support engineers.
I mentioned about
application modernization.
To support all those
hundreds of applications,
we are running 100-some
WebLogic VMs there.
The Oracle rules engine
cluster, the Oracle Service Bus,
those were complex and high maintenance.
It required a lot of customization
to support our application requirements,
and support engineers were
having a lot of challenges
to manage and support them.
With moving to AWS Cloud,
there were kind of technical limitation
around how many nodes you can include
or add in a new Oracle RAC cluster on AWS.
Let's say, tomorrow, we got requirement
for a new application, new workload,
or existing workload is going to increase
because of new customer rollout,
it was always a challenge
and hustle with AWS
to understand how I can manage
that new workload requirement.
Now, the life after Aurora Postgres.
What we did is we designed
these Aurora Postgres instances
with a writer and reader instance concept.
We not only were able to
reduce the number of nodes,
or in this case, number of instances
after we moved to Aurora Postgres,
we were able to reduce the number of nodes
of, like, nine-nodes Oracle RAC cluster
to a two-instance Aurora
Postgres database instance.
So we had one writer instance
where all the writer, like,
insert update, delete workload was going
from all the applications,
and then we created a reader instance
to support any cache refresh,
any reporting type of requirements,
or any application workload requirements
where there are selector read
operations were required.
Again, tomorrow, if a workload comes in,
more reporting requirement,
more businesses need more analytical data,
we can easily horizontally
scale this cluster
by adding more reader instances.
It is not going to take us
five different discussions
with AWS,
10 different discussions for weeks.
It's just only going to need
a select click of a button
or run a pipeline to add one
more reader instance there,
so horizontal scaling was never an issue
after we moved to our Aurora Postgres.
Headless DR, that's a very nice feature
provided by Aurora Postgres.
Now, what we did is these Aurora
Postgres database instances
were huge to support this workload.
Again, when we moved to Aurora Postgres,
we were running on the largest instance
provided by AWS on this.
So creating another compute
and the storage on DR
just to support the DR environment
was a cost of business for us.
So what we did is we created or designed
our DR solutions wherever
possible and applicable
with minimizing our availability risk
to use the headless DR.
So what is headless DR?
Headless DR is, as we
all know, like Aurora,
you can replicate or clone the storage
onto your DR recovery region.
In our case, it was, let's
say, on the west side,
but you don't need to add
any compute over there,
so you save a huge cost.
Whenever you need your
compute for a failover reason
or for any other reason,
you can add a compute to those instances
in a click of button,
and your DR database
instances will be ready
and available in minutes.
So that's what we did to manage the cost.
Wherever DR instance
compute is not needed,
we used all headless DR for those.
And with Aurora Postgres, what we achieved
was subsequent data sync lag.
It's in milliseconds,
so if you are talking about
doing a insert operation
in your writer instance,
and doing a read operation in reader,
it's less than a second,
it's in milliseconds.
So unless you have very
time-critical operations,
you can very easily isolate
your write and read,
and move them into two
different instances,
or as many instances as you want.
Same goes for DR.
If you need it, you can
run a lot of reporting
from your DR engine.
You add a computer over there,
even the cross-region replication
is pretty quick there.
So that reduced a lot of headache.
When we were on Oracle RAC,
I had to maintain a primary instance,
I had to maintain a local standby,
and then I had to maintain
a remote standby for my DR,
so we reduced a lot of
redundancy over that
with the advantage of AWS automation.
Now, before Aurora Postgres,
when we were running on Oracle,
I had mentioned earlier,
patching was a nightmare,
even on the extra data era,
or even when we were running
on AWS Custom Oracle RAC.
It used to be a weekend business.
It used to run for hours,
and you don't know until
that whole patching ends
whether you are successful
or not successful,
so it was a use risk for our business.
Runbooks to manage operational
risk and operational task.
So we were having very limited option
to create runbooks when we were running
on our Oracle RAC clusters.
It was giving us very
limited options over there.
License management,
we all know Oracle is
not cheap in the market.
You have to do annual license renewal,
you need to do annual support renewal,
so it has its own cost implication,
and you get locked down
with vendor software.
You don't have any freedoms,
you wait for their patches,
you have their lockdown with Oracle,
so Oracle basically manages and drive
what you have to do with
your application workload.
To meet our compliance, we
used to do annual DR test,
and with all these, like,
remote standby failover,
bringing up that data,
it used to take hours, as I mentioned,
so we were having, like,
larger RTO and RPOs.
Now, after Aurora Postgres,
what we were able to do,
we all know, with AWS-managed solution,
we can enable our automated patching.
In a lot of cases, all the minor
patchings are auto-enabled,
which means if you use those flags,
how you have defined
your maintenance window,
AWS is going to run automated
patching on your databases
depending on how your business runs.
Now, all our DBAs, data architects,
they can really focus on
application designing,
their application database designing,
rather than focusing on how to manage
those Oracle RAC clusters.
That gave them a good platform
to learn new technologies,
to bring development in their
professional growth, also.
And with what we were able to do,
is as we were able to
implement site reliability
engineering practices on
our application stack,
we were able to also roll
out our database reliability
engineering practice.
So DBAs were not considered as
those orthodox DBAs anymore.
They were working as reliability engineers
to ensure reliability and
stability of the database
rather than thinking about patching
and all those regular operational tasks,
which we used to do on
Oracle RAC clusters.
Easy to scale, as I mentioned.
Horizontal scaling is a button away.
You click a button or you
run your automation pipeline,
you can scale it out horizontally
as per your application need.
Significant reduction in RPO and RTO.
As I said, with Aurora Postgres,
your replication sync lag is very minimum.
You have a better cross-region
replication solution
available by AWS itself,
so it reduced our RPO and RTO factors.
When we tried to compare how much effort
we were putting on Oracle
patching and managing Oracle
versus Aurora Postgres,
we have observed more than 30%
reduction in patching effort,
which is huge, not only from
a business point of view,
but also for a database team,
how much challenges it reduce,
how much sleepless nights it can reduce
out of your calendar.
And then as I mentioned,
for security compliance
and for other compliances,
regulatory compliances,
we used to test our DR
capability every year.
What we have achieved is we
have observed that even similar,
more than 30% reduction
in those DR exercises
across the teams.
Not only database team, be
it site reliability team,
be it DevOps, be it application team,
we saw a huge improvement over those.
Now, we completed this journey,
now, the platform is there,
the foundation migration was done,
foundation is running stable
and well on AWS Cloud,
we are using most of
the AWS-managed solution
to enable us to move faster to achieve
a better go-to-market strategy.
Now, how are we scaling with AWS?
So as mentioned earlier,
we are still able to manage the same,
or even, in some cases, more
as we are growing more than
or close to 50,000
transactions per second.
This database in total
handles close to 5 billion
database transactions per day,
so you can imagine how busy is this.
So we needed a hyperscaler enabler for us
to support this workload,
and we found it with AWS.
We started this journey with
a very defined strategy.
There was no opponents,
there are no loose endpoints.
We knew exactly what was the challenge.
We knew exactly what was the risk.
We knew exactly what risk
mitigation path we have,
and what are the solution
we are going to use
for each of them.
We were able to get freed
out from this vendor locking.
We were more open-source
technology adapter right now.
We were able to modernize
all our application stack.
We were able to leverage
event-driven Kafka architecture,
which basically opened up a
lot of other options for us.
And then what, at the end of the day,
it helped us to achieve,
is our core strength is data management,
because we get so many data
points from so many claims,
so many different types of data,
because every claim is
different by its nature.
And with the complexity slowly increasing
with all the automobiles,
I think it is going to grow even more.
So we focused on our
database modernization,
we identified each layer,
we created a solution and
strategy for each of them,
and we did them in phases.
And after the initial
binary data migration done,
we took the non-binary data,
and in the second phase,
we migrated the databases
from our AWS Oracle
custom RAC cluster to AWS
Aurora Postgres cluster.
As I said, it not only enabled us
to achieve operational efficiency,
better cost mitigation strategy,
it also help us to simplify
both our application architecture
and database architecture.
So this journey was for
years, more than three years.
There were lots of partners with us
who kind of help us to
enable this journey.
We were never being able
to do this by ourselves.
So we leveraged AWS's expertise
whenever we were trying to
implement their solutions.
Then we also leveraged
Percona's Postgres expertise
when we were towards the
end of this migration,
and we needed help on their SQL expertise
and Postgres expertise,
but nonetheless, there was
another critical partner for us,
(Subrat clearing his throat)
which was Cognizant.
They were our strategic
partner from day one.
I have Chandana with me from Cognizant,
so she will be able to give
more details around it,
but nonetheless, it was a joint effort.
We all worked together, we all
worked with a concrete plan,
and at the end of the day,
we were able to achieve
all the accomplishment,
whatever we aimed for.
Thank you.
Chandana?
(audience applauding)
- Thank you, Subrat.
That was tremendous, actually.
So I'm Chandana Paul, and as
you said, I'm from Cognizant.
I manage the relationship
between Cognizant and CCC,
and based out of Chicago, I
almost did not make it here.
You know, the Midwest is slammed, right?
We had 14 inches of snow,
but here I am. (chuckles)
So as a strategic partner of CCC,
we were involved end to
end in this whole journey,
across the phases, you know,
starting from planning all
the way to production cutover.
And this continuity basically
helped with minimizing risk,
with quick issue resolution.
We were, and we are, intimately
aware of the landscape
and the applications, et cetera,
so it's really been a wonderful journey.
And I'd like to give a, maybe, you know,
just a brief about how we were engaged.
This slide actually gives a sampling
of the various areas
that we were involved in.
Some highlights that I
would like to talk about
is one Subrat mentioned,
close teamwork, right?
So there was AWS,
CCC involved, you know,
and Cognizant was involved
together as a single team.
There wasn't any difference,
so it was a one-team effort.
Cognizant was able to bring in mindshare
from similar engagements
that we have accomplished
with other customers, and so together,
we were able to, you know,
minimize risk, resolve issues quickly.
Secondly,
because we were so intimately, you know,
we had so much in-depth
knowledge of the applications
and the various objects,
we were able to put together a strategy.
I mean, you know, do the analysis,
put together a systematic
strategy for remediation,
and that remediation of the applications,
the queries,
the stored procedures, et cetera,
helped in achieving this, you know,
with minimal risk, minimal challenges.
And we were able to resolve issues
as they came up along the way.
On the DevOps front,
the DevOps strategy
was key to accelerating
migration timelines and reducing risk,
and this was achieved through automation
using parallel EKS environment,
bulk deployment across 30 clusters.
And all of this helped to
enable seamless deployment
of over 300 applications,
you know, using these applications
as well as portals, actually,
across EKS environments
with zero downtime.
So this was, you know,
that really helped along the way.
And then Cognizant, of course,
collaborated on the
actual migration efforts.
Subrat talked about using the SCT,
you know, the schema conversion
tool wherever possible,
but there was a large
number of metadata objects
that needed manual intervention, you know,
manual remediation,
customization, et cetera,
so that was achieved,
and then working, you
know, collaboratively
on the actual data migration
using the DMS tool.
On application modernization,
more than 200 applications
were modernized to JBUS, EKS,
over 500 SQL queries were remediated,
validated, et cetera.
So again, you know, large
volumes of stored procedures
were updated to PostgreSQL.
Load testing, performance
testing throughout that whole,
you know, intense process,
bringing in quick fixes,
helping through deployment,
and then of course, once
moved into production,
on the SRE standpoint,
the Cognizant team supported
all the necessary SRE functions
through 24/7 support,
and that included CloudWatch
deployment, dashboard setup,
you know, all to ensure
the reliable platform
that CCC is known to provide
for their end customers.
So again, a great journey together,
a lot of learnings, lot of best practices,
which, after completion of
this, we were actually able
to take to our other customers as well.
And we are really happy to
have you as an audience here.
I'm sure you've either embarked on
or are thinking about this
similar transformation journey.
We'd be happy to share, you know,
some of the best practices,
lessons learned, et cetera,
what to watch out for,
and so on and so forth,
so thank you very much.
(audience applauding)
- So before I conclude this session today,
if you are planning for
a database modernization,
if you are in the path of migrating
from a native database solution
to any cloud-managed database solutions,
if you're working on modifying
your application workload
from one database engine
type to another one,
don't be overwhelmed by it.
There are solutions,
there are tools available.
As long as you have identified
all your challenges,
you have a better plan and
you execute through it,
your journey will be successful.
It has happened to us,
and I'm sure it'll happen to all of you.
Thank you for your time today.